how're you guys doing today good good I
just flew in so I'm here for a day doing
this amazing what else would you rather
be doing than thank you
it's a bright friend let's talk about
bright sure I really love the entire
concept of the film I love how it sort
of inverts the whole Superman thing
where it's like oh maybe if they saw
humanity they would just become evil
yeah but also like why do we trust that
they're good at heart I think that's
completely right it's such a like
Pollyanna thing to do
yeah Lex Luthor was right I was gonna
ask whether you know just sort of
looking at the world whether this might
be the more realistic scenario for from
that sort of myth well I think any time
you're talking about something being
realistic were human being
[Music]
yeah so I'm wondering it but it's just
with superhero story time because you
know in the Guardians burrow that's
usually you know good people that learn
to be bad and wandering it's a little
cathartic in a way to work in in a story
where it's like you know what no the
person is the evil that's just yeah I
think the entire point of horror movies
is catharsis right it's like taking out
our fears in a safe way and experiencing
our fears in a safe way usually an
entertaining fun way and for sure for me
this movie what attracted to meet me
that this movie was all the fears you
have as a parent and I know the very
seed of this movie was your brother
adopting right a baby and and you put it
so well like the idea that we invite we
like invite a stranger into our house
for the next 18 years and we don't know
maybe it's well the problem for Tori as
she knew it was an alien in a spaceship
you want to be it's like you know it's
like people who want to see the good
it's the half glass full half glass but
Kyle's a realistic one cuz you brought
home a baby from a spaceship and he was
like okay I was I was siding with him a
little bit more Oh like we should be
wearing them like you should be well the
whole time
oh you're completely codependent
yeah you're like these people that lives
with a rampant alcoholic or drug addict
and booze right
oh no no no it's nothing it's nothing
there's nothing totally totally in
denial I do want to talk about the
practical aspects of this movie and I
think you especially have to do a lot of
acting in it in a shaking house and I'm
wondering if that's one of the things
that's a lot less cool-looking on set
than it is going like this you're really
good elizabeth is really good at doing
like you know you just you just tell her
these little things like that's a
difference you don't understand somebody
who's been acting on film for a long
time versus somebody who's a really
talented actor who has not acted on film
it's a different the craft of it is so
huge so being able to run around a house
and pretend like you're toppling over
coming over is something that maybe
somebody who just came out of fantastic